-The Trump administration
drafted a truly shocking
executive order
that would've directed
the secretary of defense
to seize voting machines
after the 2020 election.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Seems like almost every day
we get new details
about the threat
to our democracy posed
by Trump and his cronies
as they plotted to overturn
the 2020 election,
so, naturally,
Fox News has been laser-focused
on the issues
that matter most to Americans.
-The maker of M&M's
is giving the candy
a woke makeover.
-M&M's characters
will be redesigned
for a more
progressive world.
-The parent company
of M&M's
causing quite the stir
after announcing their candy
mascots will be getting
an "inclusive," woke makeover.
-The green M&M,
you will notice,
is no longer wearing sexy boots.
[ Laughter ]
Now, she's wearing
sensible sneakers.
Why the change?
Well, according to M&M's...
Because leading women
do not wear sexy boots.
Leading women wear frumpy shoes,
the frumpier the better.
That's the rule.
The brown M&M has "transitioned
from high stilettos
to lower block heels."
Also less sexy.
That's progress.
M&M's will not be satisfied
until every
last cartoon character
is deeply unappealing
and totally androgynous,
until the moment you wouldn't
want to have a drink
with any one of them.
That's the goal.
When you're totally turned off,
we've achieved equity.
They've won.
[ Laughter ]
-[ As Carlson ]
This used to be a country
where you could get aroused
by candy,
where you, a hot-blooded youth,
could be watching TV
with your girlfriend
and the green M&M
would come onscreen
with her full lips
and her tantalizing white boots
and you'd have
to excuse yourself
to take a cold shower
or go for a long bike ride.
And, the next morning,
your girlfriend would say,
"Are you okay?
You seem distant."
And you wouldn't have the heart
to tell her
that you were distant
because you no longer felt
any attraction to her dull,
flesh-colored human face,
as you now realized a truth
that is self-evident --
pure sexuality comes in a green,
button-shaped package
with an alluring candy shell.
So, instead, you say,
"Everything's fine, sweetie,"
and you'd drive to work,
but you'd stop
at the convenience store --
to buy a paper,
you would tell yourself.
But, once inside,
you'd also grab a bag of candy
and you'd walk to the register
praying that bag
wouldn't slip out of your
sweat-soaked palms.
And, when you paid,
hands shaking and breath quick,
the cashier would look at you
and give you a knowing nod
because, as an American man,
he understood what you wanted --
to [bleep] a piece of candy.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
And I'm sorry to say we don't
live in that country anymore.
So that's what Fox News
was focused on
as the rest of us
digested the news
that Trump and his cronies
had crafted a plan
to seize voting machines,
a plan that was, apparently,
so advanced,
they'd written up
a draft executive order
that involved the military.
-The January 6th Committee
now has access
to a trove of Donald Trump's
White House records.
Among them,
according to Politico,
a draft executive order
to seize voting machines
and keep him in office.
-Do you have proof
that there was someone
inside the United States
military,
working on this premise
of actually seizing
voting machines?
-Well, we have information that,
between the
Department of Justice,
a plan was put forth
to potentially seize
voting machines in the country
and utilize
Department of Defense assets
to make that happen.
-But I'm not going to melt
in your hand.
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to melt in your mouth.
-Do you, uh, do you promise?
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
[ Laughter ]
You guys got to give me
a heads-up
when the clips are about to end.
Jesus.
[ Laughter ]
Now, where were "me"? Right.
I'm not often shocked
by Trump's antics anymore,
but I have to say this
strikes me as a pretty big deal.
It's one thing,
to have a meeting
with a bunch of crazy people,
like Rudy or the pillow lunatic
or that lawyer who looks like
she kidnapped 101 Dalmatians,
only to find out later
they were actually just
three poodles
who'd been spray-painted.
[ As Sidney Powell ]
What is the meaning of this?!
But it's another thing
to get a bunch
of high-level government
officials involved
and draft an actual plan
and sometimes I feel like
we're going to be hearing
revelations like this one
for the rest of our lives.
Someday, I'll be sitting
in a nursing home,
looking out the window
at my favorite tree,
and a nurse will come in
and say, "Did you hear?
Trump was training
an army of rats
to chew the wires
out of voting machines."
[ Laughter ]
And, according to Politico,
whoever wrote
this executive order
had access to sensitive
government information
that was not publicly known.
Wow!
So it could've been
a high-level
government executive
or a general
or literally anybody
at Mar-a-Lago.
Trump was pretty loose
[ Laughter ]
with the top secret information.
I'm sure, at least once,
he interrupted a wedding
just to read aloud
from the X-Files.
[ As Trump ]
You may kiss the bride
in just a second, but, first,
I think you're going
to want to hear
what went down at Roswell.
[ Laughter ]
So, whoever wrote
this executive order
was presumably someone who had
access to government secrets,
which is pretty crazy.
This time,
we just happened to get lucky,
since Trump is too dumb
to get his way
and a bunch of people stopped
him by threatening to quit.
But what happens next time
a Republican politician wants
to use the military
to stay in power?
Are we just supposed to hope
they get distracted
by an M&M commercial?
"I want the military
to seize voting machines
and impose martial law.
Wait a second.
Who is that angelic creature?
[ Laughter ]
No, wait.
Never mind.
She's wearing flats!"
[ Laughter ]
"Back to treason."
And I would just like
to point out
to all the people who thought
calling Trump's plan
an attempted coup
was hysterical,
this latest executive order is
just more proof
that the threat was very real.
Sure, the various schemes
were easy to dismiss at the time
because the people advocating
for them were known weirdos,
but, it turns out, Trump was
actually listening to them.
-One of the president's
visitors today,
Mike Lindell,
the founder of MyPillow,
was seen over here
at the White House,
outside the West Wing.
A White House official
did tell me, Wolf,
that it is believed that
the president and Lindell met.
-A Washington Post photographer
got a close-up
of the notes that he was
carrying with him and, Jake,
when you zoom in on them,
you can see
that he is talking
about the election.
Things like martial law
are mentioned,
the words "taken immediately
to save the Constitution."
-The guy from MyPillow
is carrying documents
and talking
to President Trump,
presumably, about declaring
martial law.
-And it's easy to laugh it off
and say,
"He was never going to listen
to the MyPillow guy,"
but he invited him over --
for non-pillow reasons,
it should be noted.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, if I said,
"I'm never going to take advice
from Mike Lindell,"
you'd all believe me.
But if I also said,
"And I told him that much
at dinner last night,"
you might think, "Wait, what?"
[ Laughter ]
For all we know,
they took Lindell's notes
and turned them
into an executive order, too,
in which case it would be
the first executive order
that used a promo code.
[ As Lindell ]
Enter the promo code
"Sweet Dreams"
and you won't just save
the Constitution.
You'll save an additional 30%.
[ Laughter ]
This is yet more proof,
as we've said many times,
that you can be
both incredibly dumb
and incredibly dangerous
at the same time.
For example, Trump's cronies
also had a plan in place,
at roughly the same time,
to forge fake certificates
from Trump electors
in seven states Trump lost.
And, of course --
and, I guess, thank God --
they put their dumbest henchmen
in charge.
-We have breaking news
on efforts
from the former
president's allies
to undermine
the 2020 election results.
Now, according to sources
with direct knowledge
of the scheme,
Trump campaign officials,
led by Rudy Giuliani,
oversaw efforts to put forward
illegitimate electors
from seven states
that the former president
actually lost.
-It was basically
Rudy Giuliani
and all these other misfits
leading the charge of this plot,
intricately involved
in these efforts
in December of 2020
to put forward fake electors
from seven states
that Trump lost.
That was a major part of this
overall plan by Team Trump
to overturn the 2020
election results,
back when Congress counted the
electoral votes on January 6.
So, the point was to have
Vice President Pence
accept these
fake Trump electors,
rather than the valid
Biden ones.
One source said
there were several calls
between Trump campaign officials
and state GOP operatives
to round up fake electors
on a state-by-state level.
-Rudy Giuliani
rounding up electors
is like an "Ocean's Eleven"
where everyone's skill was
being bat[bleep] crazy.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Giuliani ]
This is Nancy from Phoenix.
When it comes to being a crazy,
she's got us covered.
This is Frank from Tempe.
When you need crazy,
he's your guy.
[ Laughter ]
Patricia's from Scottsdale.
She's like
an expert safecracker,
but, instead of cracking safes,
she's being crazy.
[ Laughter ]
Trump and his team
tried every path
they could possibly think of
to overturn the results
of the election
and they came very close
to pulling it off.
These are the kinds of schemes
they're cooking up
when they're not at home,
late at night,
fantasizing about M&M's
[ Laughter ]
while resting their heads
on their...
-Pillow.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.